bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi un
attentat au colis piégé a fait un mort
et cinq blessés à paris le paquet a été
livré à cabinet d'avocats c'est une
secrétaire qui a été tué aucune piste
n'est privilégiée ce soir peut-être une
nouvelle grève à la sncf et à la ratp la
cgt annonce que le principe d'un
mouvement de 24 heures et à qui il
s'agit de peser sur les négociations en
cours dans le débat sur le pouvoir
d'achat le gouvernement précise les
modalités du paiement des rtt qui n'ont
pas été prises en 2007 elles seront
rémunérées en salaires avec une
majoration de 10 %
l'appel de nicolas sarkozy aux
ravisseurs d'ingrid betancourt le
président de la république a enregistré
un message vidéo à l'intention des farc
pour demander sa libération
les premières réactions sont sceptiques
à bogota
faut-il croire à un retournement de
situation en irak depuis des semaines
les attentats sont en forte baisse
des centaines de milliers de personnes
ont pu regagner leurs foyers
enfin un foie gras s'en gaver les oies
ou les canards c'est ce que propose une
chaîne britannique
à noël pour répondre à la polémique sur
les droits des animaux les puristes sont
indignés dégustation à la fin de ce
journal
l'explosion s'est produite en fin de
matinée et elle reste ce soir encore
mystérieuse la secrétaire d'un cabinet
d'avocat a donc été tué par un colis
piégé a mené par un coursier dans les
beaux quartiers de paris
un cabinet qui gère essentiellement des
affaires immobilières et commercial cinq
autres personnes ont été blessées dont
une grièvement
audrey goutard laurent des bois cinq
heures après les faits la police
scientifique est toujours sur place les
enquêteurs relèvent encore les indices
dans le cabinet d'avocats ou à exploser
le colis piégé une bombe qui a coûté la
vie à une secrétaire et grièvement
blessé un avocat on a vu le corps d'une
jeune femme blonde
pour le sortir du bâtiment couverte de
sang avec un monsieur qui se tenait la
tête
à 12h50 un homme casqué se présentent au
quatrième étage du 52 boulevard
malesherbes
c'est un cabinet d'avocats il est
accueilli à la réception que l'on voit
ici sur une vidéo promotionnelle
la secrétaire prend la caissette en
boîte lui tend à l'intérieur il y à la
bombe
il semble des premières constatations
qu'il s'agisse de deux engins explosifs
réunis dans la même police qui ont été
reliés à un dispositif de mise à feu qui
a fonctionné lors de l'ouverture du
positif pour la brigade criminelle la
faire se présente complexe les cinq
avocats du cabinet traite chacun de
nombreux dossiers principalement
immobilier et au premier étage de cet
immeuble se trouve un autre cabinet
d'avocats
l'ancien de nicolas sarkozy une points
si dense selon les enquêteurs il n'y a
aucun lien avec le l'ancien cabinet du
président de la république qui se trouve
au premier étage qui est clairement
identifiée par une plaque
professionnelle des actuels associés
alors que là on au quatrième étage avec
des plaques clairement indiquant
clairement que les le nom des associés
au sein de ce cabinet ce soir les
policiers entendaient encore l'ensemble
des avocats du cabinet tous les témoins
qui ont assisté au drame
à la recherche du moindre élément
personnel ou professionnel
aucune piste n'est donc privilégié c'est
ce qu'a indiqué la ministre de
l'intérieur michèle alliot marie
arrivés sur place les condamnations sont
bien sûr unanime
arnaud boutet sylvain gauthier moins
d'une heure après l'explosion ce
quartier chic de paris se retrouve
bouclée par des militaires qui
patrouillaient avec les renforts de
police le déploiement devient vite
impressionnant l' enquête débute à peine
et les condamnations se multiplient la
première vient rapidement boulevard
malesherbes par le maire de paris
il faut absolument que l'on soit très
ferme très déterminé dans notre
condamnation de secret mi7 incline voir
aujourd'hui un colis piégé déposé dans
un cabinet d'avocats qui tue une
secrétaire et qui blesse et avocats
c'est l'horreur absolue
pour la ministre de l'intérieur il n'y a
pas d'erreur possible sur la cible le
cabinet était bel et bien vu
il s'agit d'un cabinet d'avocats qui
s'occupe d'affaires civiles
principalement 9e et
les différentes classes d autres
activités qui ont lieu dans cet immeuble
sont prêts nets qui sont cas apparemment
c'est vraiment qu'est-ce qu'elle de ce
cabinet ce soir le ps mais aussi
l'elysée condamne à leur tour
l'explosion du colis piégés pour soir
dindin boudaoud vous êtes en direct
boulevard malesherbes à paris quelle
direction explore l'anc est peut-être à
vide il faut savoir que ce soir les
enquêteurs de la section antiterroriste
de la brigade criminelle de paris se
trouve toujours sur place à la recherche
évidemment du moindre indice
on sait désormais désormais que le
cabinet d'avocats parisien a été donc
visés par cet attentat
il est clair que les policiers vont du
coup s'est intéressé de près de très
près au dossier traité par ses avocats
spécialisés dans le droit civil et
immobilier ils vont aussi s'intéresser
aux vieilles affaires par exemple un
proche du cabinet se souvient avec une
des avocates avaient porté plainte en
2005 contre le nomme pour harcèlement
depuis cette affaire a été s'est
terminée par un non lieu
c'est une des pistes que les enquêteurs
vont explorer david bien évidemment une
piste parmi d'autres
merci zine dine dans la sphère du double
meurtre des gardes civils le couple
interpellé hier serait bien impliqué
c'est ce qu'indique le ministère de
l'intérieur qui parle d' un faisceau
d'indicés concordants la femme
interpellée est en tout cas une des
militantes de théa les plus recherchés
d'espagne le troisième membre du
commando est toujours en fuite des
images signées pascal pons
en bref encore la cour d'appel de paris
a accordé un régime de semi liberté à
jean marc rouillan cofondateur de
l'organisation armée d'extrême gauche
action directe
il était incarcéré depuis près de 21 ans
il travaillera dans la journée dans une
maison d'édition et passera ses nuits et
ses week-ends en prison
deuxième titre de l'actualité la
perspective d'une nouvelle grève dans
les transports publics un préavis de la
cgt a été déposés à la ratp pour le 12
décembre
du côté de la sncf où les négociations
se poursuivaient aujourd'hui le principe
une action de 24 heures semble également
acquis même si aucune date n'a été fixée
il s'agit toujours de la réforme des
régimes spéciaux de retraite en écoute
didier le reste pour la cg certainement
une nouvelle étape de grève des
cheminots pour effectivement peser sur
les négociations
parce que je le redis il ya des points
de blocage aujourd'hui qui demeure et
qui sent pas admissible
notamment du côté du gouvernement même
si la sncf doit encore effectivement on
met un peu plus sur la table en matière
de rémunération notamment
bonsoir agnès molinier vous êtes en
direct au siège de la ratp alors faut-il
vraiment s'attendre à une nouvelle
épreuve de force
ce que l'on peut dire david dans l'état
actuel des choses c'est qu'il ya
effectivement un risque de grève à la
ratp dans le métro parisien pour
mercredi prochain une grève d'une
journée non reconductible ce que l'on
appelle une grève carrée
seule la cgt y appelle et on viens de
l'entendre avec didier le reste c'est
une stratégie peser sur les négociations
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'elle avait promis
à sa base en suspendant le mouvement de
novembre dernier
la grève est utilisé ici comme une
menace pour l'instant la cgt est seul
sur ce terrain parmi les grands
syndicats et elle essaie de faire la
même chose à la sncf en proposant une
journée de grève avant la fin des
négociations
mais ce soir déjà la cfdt vient de
décliner cette offre
elle préfère l attendre la fin des
discussions le 20 décembre
alors côté train il est encore un peu
tôt ce soir pour y voir plus clair il
faut encore attendre demain une nouvelle
réunion des syndicats de cheminots
merci agnès côté pouvoir d'achat on en
sait davantage sur le déblocage des rtt
annoncées par le gouvernement la semaine
dernière sortez vos calculettes celles
qui n'ont pas été prises au 31 décembre
prochain pourront être payé en salaire
avec une majoration de 10 % c'est ce
qu'indique le projet de loi et en
échange les patrons bénéficieront d'une
exonération de charges mais seulement
sur les dix premiers jours racheter il
junca mathieu dreujou se faire payer les
jours de rtt accumulés dans les
entreprises ce sera possible dès l'an
prochain
principales modalités seront payés les
rtt qui n'ont pas été prises au 31
décembre 2007
ou celle stockée sur un compte épargne
temps il faudra en faire la demande
avant le 30 juin 2008
ensuite ces jours seront payés 10 % de
plus au minimum que les jours travaillés
normaux enfin les dix premiers jours de
rtt monétiser seront exonérés de charges
sociales
de quoi inciter patrons et salariés dans
cette entreprise de services
informatiques parisienne
la mesure a été accueillie dans
l'enthousiasmé général
les personnes ici on dit jours de rtt
par an
donc si celles qui choisissent de
monétiser certes était de les travailler
ça veut dire pour nous dit jour de plus
de travail côté employé c'est la même
satisfaction en choisissant la
monétisation cet ingénieur gagnera 1700
euros net de plus cette année tout en
dynamisant l'entreprise vont pouvoir
lâcher le monde page et un mois de
salaire en plus quoi
ici il ne reste plus qu'à se mettre
d'accord sur les détails de mise en
place de la mesure le texte sera
présenté la semaine prochaine en conseil
des ministres
et puis sachez que l'exonération de la
redevance audiovisuelle est bel et bien
terminée pour 780 mille foyers âgées et
modestes qui était jusque-là exemptés
mais ils ne paieront que la moitié de la
somme
c'est à dire 58 euros le parti
socialiste a voté contre cet amendement
et dénoncent une régression sociale
j'en viens maintenant à la colombie
c'est du jamais vu dans ce genre de
situation nicolas sarkozy s'est donc
adressé publiquement et solennellement
au chef des farc par vidéo interposée
il lui demande la libération d'ingrid
betancourt d'ici à noël pour des raisons
humanitaires le président de la
république a également enregistré un
message radio à l'intention d'ingrid
betancourt elle-même amaury guibert
daniel les drapeaux français intitulé
officiel
l'allocution de nicolas sarkozy
apportant une particularité le chef des
les sous titres espagnols car le message
du chef de l'état et destinés à la
colombie à une grippe bettencourt aux
autres otages mais aussi et c'est
exceptionnel alors jolie et le chef des
forces armées révolutionnaires manuel
marulanda
monsieur marulanda je vous demande
solennellement de relâcher ingrid
betancourt et de ne pas porter sur votre
compte conscience le risque que ferait
peser sa disparition c'est aujourd'hui
une femme à bout de forces
je forme un rêve celui de voir ingrid au
milieu des siens pour noël pour la
famille bettencourt ce message est une
raison d'espérer
alors que les négociations semblaient
dans l'impasse sakho 7 frais compris il
ya urgence si flammes qui en train de
s'éteindre maman l'entrée de mourir son
pib à bientôt
soit il va mourir il faut agir très vite
mais les farc ont répandu ce soir plutôt
sèchement en appelant nicolas sarkozy à
plus d'impartialité
sans doute n'ont elles pas apprécié ces
mots du président français a adressé
directement à une grippe bettencourt
dans un autre message à la radio cette
fois ci je veux vous dire chers
ingrid mon admiration pour votre dignité
pour votre courage dans une situation où
des êtres plus faible aurait perdu
jusqu'à leur humanité
ces mots parviendront-ils jusqu'à ingrid
betancourt détenue quelque part dans la
jungle colombienne
ce sera sans doute possible car le
message de nicolas sarkozy a été diffusé
à plusieurs reprises sur les ondes de
radio france internationale
je suis nicole brésil c'est l'elysée qui
a assuré la traduction espagnole
dans une lettre rendue publique la
semaine dernière ingrid betancourt
disait qu'elle écoutait régulièrement et
refi demain la radio ouvrira son antenne
à ses enfants qui pourront à leur tour
diffuser des messages de soutien alors
quel impact peut avoir ce message qui
est ce manuel marulanda à qui s'adresse
le président de la république et comment
fonctionnent les farc dont il est le
chef
les questions et les réponses avec
dorothée olliéric et patrick desmulie
qui est manuel marulanda c'est cet homme
le chef et fondateur des farc les forces
armées révolutionnaires de colombie
mouvement d'obédience marxiste qu'il a
créée en 1964 et qu'il dirige toujours
quelque part dans la jungle colombienne
sous ses ordres il serait 17 mille
combattants environ 60% d'hommes et 40 %
de femmes
les farc mène une lutte des classes au
nom de la révolution mais il se finance
grâce aux rançons des prises d'otages et
au narcotrafic
quels sont les précédents jamais un chef
d'état étranger n'a lancé un appel
semblable à celui de nicolas sarkoz les
cas de libération sont extrêmement rares
en 2001 un colonel de l'armée
colombienne a été libéré après les
supplications de sa famille en revanche
les farc ont rejeté la demande de cet
enfant souffrant d'un cancer
il voulait voir son père otages revenir
auprès de lui mais pour les farc
délibérations doivent rentrer dans le
cadre d'un accord humanitaire d échange
de prisonniers comme pour ingrid
betancourt
outre les séquestrés politique trois
mille otages seraient toujours détenus
par les farc dans la jungle pour eux
aucun échange humanitaire possible seule
possibilité l'opération militaire ou la
rançon quel est le rôle des américains
dans le dossier des otages pour
l'instant george bush reste extrêmement
discret il a téléphoné à son homologue
colombien à la suite de la diffusion des
images des trois otages américains aux
mains des farc
reste que les états unis financent à
coups de millions de dollars la lutte en
colombie contre les narcotrafiquants
autant dire que les états unis
pourraient jouer un rôle mais dans ce
dossier les américains ont toujours
refusé la négociation avec les sharks 1
ce soir le président colombien alvaro
uribe n'a pas officiellement réagi
en revanche une ancienne médiatrice
estime que cet appel n'aura aucun effet
quant aux farc eux mêmes on l'a entendu
il parle d'une initiative louable mais
partial toujours à l'étranger une
voiture piégée a fait 15 morts à bagdad
elle a explosé dans une rue commerçante
près d'une mosquée chiite alors en
attentats en irak
rien que de très banal direz vous et
pourtant si nous l'évoquons ce soir
c'est parce que ces carnages sont
devenus presque exceptionnel
personne n'en parle plus l'irak a
disparu de l'avant scène de l'actualité
est pourtant une nouvelle ère est
peut-être en train de s'ouvrir après des
années de bain de sang quotidien la
situation semble
en voie de pacification en quête de
renault bernard avec moussa ibrahim sur
place en irak
cela faisait des semaines qu'il n'était
pas sorti de chez lui adel al khayari
via adhamiyah il y à un mois à peine
c'était l'un des quartiers les plus
dangereux de bagdad
enfin le quartier il avait évité ni à ma
droite
cai bas à gauche des hommes en armes à
bagdad on en voit encore mais cela ne
sont pas des terroristes
sur le ton de la plaisanterie la milice
du quartier filtre désormais la
circulation
on a fait la chasse aux voitures piégées
on en a trouvé 15 et aussi des explosifs
au bord des routes à bagdad l'espoir est
revenu
impensable le mois dernier les mariages
ont repris la deuxième semaine du
mariage pattes avant et servir pas il ne
faisait pas
ce retour au calme relatif est la
conséquence de trois facteurs
les américains n'ont jamais été aussi
nombreux cent soixante mille hommes dans
tout le pays
à grand renfort de dollars washington à
négocier avec les tribus sunnites
elles ont progressivement abandonné leur
soutien à al qaïda enfin grâce à
l'intervention de l'iran les milices
chiites ont accepté de faire taire leurs
armes pour le moment
résultat depuis le début de l'année le
nombre de civils tués chaque mois a été
divisé par quatre pour les attentats
suicide
ils sont passés de 59 à 16 par mois
professeur à l'université adel al
caillard n'a pas encore repris ses cours
mais il peut à nouveau faire ses courses
dans les magasins mais il risque gros à
l'époque il a eu deux foires voiture
piégée ici des voix le magasin et
finalement j'ai tout s'achète et les
américains l'ont compris définitivement
à bagdad l'ambiance a bien changé sur
les murs de protection érigé contre les
voitures piégées des artistes peignent
désormais les fresques ses murs sont
vraiment au plus haut maintenant on leur
met de la couleur et ça leur donne une
autre allure mais attention le tableau
n'est peut-être pas aussi dit vick
bagdad et l'ouest du pays sont peut-être
plus sûres mais l'insécurité s'est
déplacé vers le nord
et puis politiquement l'irak est loin
d'être stabilisée on parle toujours
d'une partition du pays entre ses
différentes communautés
bonsoir l'un de chalvron vous êtes en
direct de washington est ce que
l'opinion américaine est en train de
devenir optimiste sur cette situation en
irak
oui vous savez le sujet de l'irak a
quasiment disparu de la une où alors
quand il y est c'est pour de bonnes
nouvelles c'est par exemple général
petraeus qui annonce que les violences
ont diminué de 60% que le nombre de
soldats américains tués en irak est
passé de 126 ans mais à 37 en novembre
ou encore qu' al-qaïda a été
définitivement chassés de bagdad et des
informations comme celles-là qui font
rentrer dans la
des américains est bien que le sujet
n'est plus un sujet de préoccupation est
d'ailleurs dans la campagne électorale
qui fait rage actuellement est bien
l'irak est passée au second plan au
profit de sujets plus intérieure comme
l'économie la crise immobilière où les
problèmes de santé alors cet optimisme
l'attend n'est pas partagé par les
militaires qui savent mieux que
quiconque que la situation reste fragile
à la merci d'un attentat spectaculaire
d'un nouveau retournement de telle ou
telle faction et surtout ils savent que
d'ici le mois de juillet il faudra
réduire leurs effectifs de 21 mille cinq
cents hommes c'est la promesse de george
bush et qu'à ce moment là il rentre roi
nouveau dans une zone de tous les
dangers
merci alain toujours aux etats-unis une
nouvelle fusillade la nuit dernière dans
l'état du nebraska cette fois huit
personnes ont été tuées en plein centre
commercial et à l'heure des achats de
noël
le tireur a ensuite retourné son arme
contre lui il s'agissait d'un jeune
homme de 19 ans il avait laissé un mot
indiquant qu'il allait je cite devenir
célèbre il était décrit comme quelqu'un
de renfermé souffrent de lourds
problèmes émotionnels
direction la chine maintenant on
n'évoquait avant-hier ce classement de
l' ocde sur le niveau scolaire et bien
il faut savoir que les chinois ont
massivement investi dans la connaissance
ces dernières années le taux
d'analphabétisme par exemple très
important il ya peu est passé à 5 %
seulement de la population
même s'il ya encore de grandes
différences entre la ville et la
campagne
le grand bond en avant de l'école
chinoise c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé pascal golomer
sylvain viaut hms triumph ou chun le
bonheur éternel c'est le nom de ce
village perdu au milieu des grandes
plaines agricoles du nord de la chine un
petit village mais qui a son école
primaire
200 élèves qui habitent les fermes
alentour et une douzaine d'enseignants
parmi eux mademoiselle jo une jeune
diplômée d'anglais qui vient ici
enseigné pendant un an
bénévolat après deux semaines de
formation
on lui a donné la petite classe pour
l'école c'est une aubaine j'espère
pouvoir transmettre les connaissances
que j'ai acquises dans mon école pour
que ses enfants puissent ensuite partir
de la campagne est allé à la ville pour
avoir une vie meilleure
ils enrichissent leur connaissance c'est
le plus important dans le centre de
pékin
c'est en voiture que les parents
déposent leurs enfants devant l'école
je tiens à l'école primaire publique la
plus réputée de la bible dans ses locaux
flambant neufs
elle accueille 1500 élèves 45 élèves par
classe et à chaque matière son
professeur
mademoiselle son enseigne le chinois et
comme à tous les enseignants l'école lui
fournit un ordinateur portable relié à
internet
l'ordinateur est indispensable pour les
profs qui préparent leurs cours pour les
élèves qui veulent acquérir de nouvelles
connaissances dans la salle voisine
ce sont les enfants qui sont devant
l'ordinateur mais certainement pas pour
jouer
nous sommes ici en cours d'informatique
un peu plus loin c'est le cours
d'anglais l'apprentissage commence dès
le cours préparatoire
à l'école de lyon fosun aussi les élèves
ont droit à un cours d'anglais avec
magnétophone mais ici pas d'ordinateur
ni de dessin animé l'école on n'a pas
les moyens mais pas question de demander
une participation financière aux parents
pas même pour les deux films projetés au
cours de l'année seules activités
extrascolaires et proposer les élèves
n'ont rien à payer tout est gratuit
tout est pris en charge par l'état les
livres aussi sont gratuits comme tous
les frais scolaires
ça facilite vraiment notre travail à
pékin aussi l'école publique et gratuite
en théorie seulement pour s'offrir de
tels équipements
le directeur de l'école chettia
bénéficient de l'aide de quelques
généreux sponsors il ya beaucoup de
parents qui veulent mettre leurs enfants
dans cette école
certains travaillent dans des
entreprises des ministères avec lesquels
on a un accord on accueille les enfants
et en échange l'employeur nous apporte
un soutien financier à chaque foyer
une école publique d'élite pour l'élite
les meilleurs élèves d'aujourd'hui
deviendront peut-être demain de généreux
contributeurs les enfants de lyon
fonctionnaires sont bien loin de ce
monde là malgré de belles promesses
l'école publique n'a pas combler
l'énorme fossé qui sépare encore la
ville et les campagnes chinoises
elle a même parfois creuser un peu plus
les cols toujours mais en france avec le
mouvement étudiant une nouvelle journée
de mobilisation a réuni entre trois et
cinq mille manifestants selon les
sources
ici à paris contre la loi pécresse sur
l'autonomie des enseignants mais aussi
des chercheurs
quelques incidents les ont opposés aux
forces de l'ordre en fin de cortège
moins d'une dizaine d'universités sont
encore touchées par le mouvement ce soir
des images signées frédérick basile la
réforme du fret à la sncf c'est un
immense chantier et il est contesté
quelques points de repères d'abord
sachez que le fret représente un
milliard huit cent soixante quinze
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
pour 2006 mais accuse 260 millions
d'euros de pertes pour 20000 employés
directs ou indirects alors la sncf
souhaite rationaliser son réseau en
supprimant certaines lignes de proximité
jugé trop peu rentable
des milliers d'emplois pourrait donc
également être supprimés lemay des
petites entreprises régionales pour être
aussi en pâtir
elles sont très inquiètes reportage à
béziers hélène verts ni frédéric bibal
ce wagon la quittes béziers pour rallier
le port de sète à 50 km à son bord des
tubes de 25 tonnes pièce chaque semaine
l'entreprise a besoin d'expédier cinq à
six wagons mais à compter du 10 décembre
la sncf a décidé de suspendre ce trafic
ferroviaire et transports faro presse
effectif de treize elle porta et si ça
vient impacter de façon importante des
résultats de cette ligne de production
bat peut-être les actionnaires ont notre
maison mère dira ah ben on peut
envisager de faire cette activité
ailleurs que seuls 3 dans cet autre
entreprise c'est chaque jour qu'on
rentre ou qu'on fait partir du matériel
par fret
les volumes sont faibles mais cette
régularité quotidienne est fondamentale
pour la société
il n'est pas concevable de recevoir des
matériels pour l'entretien périodique à
raison de deux fois par mois
ça veut dire que vos clients laisserait
tomber ça veut dire que le client là
serait tombé face à la colère des
patrons de pme
la sncf s'est engagée à ne laisser
aucune entreprise sans solution mais son
objectif est bien de supprimer au plus
vite les wagons isolés trop coûteux et
de privilégier les gros qui a nous a
travaillé pour éviter qu'une machine
producteurs j'ai amené attiré 2,3 petit
wagon plutôt massifier faire en sorte
que ce qui la vraie vocation sur des
longs parcours
avoir vingt à trente wagons derrière ce
qui correspond à une vraie économie
d'échelle et une ré performance ne
devrait donc rester à terme que les
grosses plateformes dans le transport de
marchandises
la nécessité de rentabilité a pris le
pas sur le service public politique
bertrand delanoë dévoile les
personnalités et d'ouverture le qui
seront sur ses listes en vue des
municipales de mars prochain
parmi elles le comédien philippe
torreton l'ex président de l'unef bruno
julliard ou encore le sociologue jean
louis missika jeff vite imbert christian
leroux ségolène royal sort son livre
bertrand delanoë sort sa liste celle des
candidats venus d'ailleurs
le leader étudiant bruno julliard la
réalisatrice yamina benguigui
le comédien philippe torreton ils se
présenteront aux suffrages des parisiens
qui paraît-il ne s'intéresseraient
qu'aux municipales
personne ne parle du congrès du parti
socialiste ni des élections
présidentielles parle que de l'avis de
paris
ce serait une grave erreur derrière 2
ça se perd dans cette élection en ayant
des arrière pensées pour les prochaines
élections présidentielles pas d'arrière
pensée dans l'immédiat bertrand delanoë
n'a que paris en tête pour le reste on
verra plus tard
beaucoup de militants revanche comme
dans cette réunion du ps parisiens ont
déjà leurs convictions quelqu'un qui est
très discipliné c'est ce qu'ils nous
font parce que le parti par un petit peu
dans tous les sens
bertrand delanoë pourrait-il succéder à
françois hollande ce soir celui ci fait
en tout cas preuve de bienveillance même
si bien sûr il n'est question que de
paris suis très content que bertrand
delanoë donne de l'ampleur à sa campagne
la popularité de bertrand delanoë à
paris c'est un atout à l'est quant au
principal intéressé
si je dois faire encore plus pour mon
pays et pour l'idéal dans lequel je
crois et je crois encore plus cher le ps
cherche un patron
on a une petite idée de qui le maire de
paris d réduit ans et plus en bref un
contretemps pour la navette spatiale le
lancement d'atlantis avec à son bord le
français léopold eyharts tse reporté
d'au moins 24 heures en raison d'une
anomalie technique
les préparatifs du 21e téléthon les
parrain et marraine de cette édition
2007 liane foly et kad merad donneront
le coup d'envoi demain sur france 2 bien
sûr dès 18h50 en direct de l'esplanade
du château de vincennes les 30 heures de
direct présentée par sophie davant et
nagui le pari cette année est de
transformer les essais médicaux en
succès thérapeutique
n'oubliez pas les quatre chiffres
importants du week-end le 36 37 image
signée marie claire denis
l'environnement on connaît les
prototypes de maisons à basse
consommation mais le défi des grands
constructeurs immobiliers consiste à les
produire en série l'un d'eux a mis au
point une habitation qui économiserait
jusqu'à 80 % d'énergie en comparaison
d'une construction classique
le système est ingénieux reportage en
eure-et-loir gilles marine est jacques
gérard la maison s'ouvre vers le sud car
le soleil lui est indispensable
ici on a beau chercher du séjour aux
chambres et jusqu'à la salle de bain
aucun radiateur pas de chauffage
traditionnel seul dans le salon la
présence d'un mur qui intrigue
en fait c'est le seul radiateur de la
maison la lumière va venir impacter la
brique la brise va charger la chaleur
venant de la lumière et le restituer au
système de ventilation qui lui va après
avoir redistribué dans la maison la
chaleur stockée par le mur et diffusée
par simple rayonnement en cas de grand
froid à partir de -5° la maison peut
compter sur un poêle à bois haute
performance mais ce n'est pas tout cette
borne surgi du jardin à trente mètres de
la maison aspire l'air extérieur dans un
conduit souterrain appelé puits canadien
qui le réchauffe naturellement jusqu'à
14 degrés puis il le mélange à de l'air
chaud issu de la maison
résultat en combinant le mur de brique
et le puits canadien température
intérieure 21° st il fait 9 degrés
dehors 9 degrés dehors 21,5 à
l'intérieur le secret l'utilisation de
matériaux d'isolation performant et de
techniques de chauffage originale et
simple on n'a pas voulu non plus faire
une débauche de technologie
l'idée demain c'est quand même de vendre
ses maisons et de les vendre au meilleur
prix
on va dire entre guillemette
démocratiser la maison basse
consommation que ça ne s'adresse plus à
une élite 125 mille euros prix affichés
en version de base pour cent mètres
carrés l'habitat nouveau entend bien
concurrencer le pavillon traditionnel
mais pour économiser 80 % d'énergie il
faut apporter un soin extrême à
l'isolation le défi sera de produire
cette nouvelle maison en grande série
une belle image est désormais
traditionnel approche de noël à lyon 4
millions de personnes sont attendues
pour la 9e fête des lumières ce
spectacle unique en europe est gratuit
pour le public est l'occasion de visiter
la ville de manière féerique façades
d'immeubles places jardins sont mises en
valeur par ses scénographie lumineuse et
politique c'est à découvrir jusqu'à
dimanche
et pour ceux qui n'ont aucune idée et
bien sachez qu hit parade des jouets les
plus commandés cette année on trouve les
poupées pour les filles c'est original
les figurines et les robots pour les
garçons caroline thébaux marie cros
tu peut m'apporter un pitch une bonne
tactique rock dub musiques papa noël ou
même cottinet la nuit et surtout des
cartes des commandes que le père noël a
parfois bien du mal à déchiffrer
alors récapitulons côté filles il faudra
courir après les pet shop à 4 euros
l'unité
ces mini animaux ont pris la grosse tête
et se font déjà désirer on va devoir
courir tout paris pour trouver des trucs
en plastoc
moi j'en pense c'est une galère j'ai pas
du tout envie de courir tous les matchs
déjà fait trois magasins et pour les
tromper
les jeux sont faits ariste en tête
l'éternel barbie à 25 euros
l'indétrônable charlotte aux fraises à
40 et plus inattendu l'avion polly
pocket à 65 euros
côté garçons le père noël devrait miser
sur les produits dérivés et il y a du
choix à grandes tendances et les
licences par exemple spider man ici tout
le rayon avec notamment la figurine
parce que ça c'est le personnage avec
lequel on refait l'histoire
bien évidemment les hélicoptères et puis
aussi la panoplie pascal noël les
enfants ils veulent être le super héros
au coude à coude il y a aussi les autres
héros des dessins animés vie de films 30
euros en moyenne
décollage réussi pour cet hélicoptère
radio commandé un hit parade très
demandé effectivement pour essayer de
quatre on va plus la voir pour le moment
vous avez peut-être pouvoir le retrouver
en fin de semaine mais là les délais
s'allongent malgré les livraisons
quotidiennes noël représente ici 50 % du
chiffre d'affaires salut jouer tous les
soirs sont quasiment déjà tous vendus le
lendemain en moyenne les enfants
trouveront cette cadeaux au pied du
sapin
certains risquent de ne plus savoir où
donner de la tête noël côté table
maintenant avec du foie gras s'en gaver
les oies ou les canards c'est ce que
propose une chaîne britannique pour
répondre à la polémique sur les droits
des animaux alors les puristes sont
indignés car il faut bien être honnête
ce n'est pas tout à fait du foie gras
petit comparatif à londres avec maryse
burgot et dominique marault tél sa
spécialité est entre autres le foie gras
ce chef français réputé est installé à
londres
depuis dix ans a donc goûté pour nous ce
nouveau produit ça une texture pâteuse
sèche plutôt salée sincèrement si vous
me dites c'est du foie gras j'y crois
pas à
le faux gras à très intéressant ce faux
gras est un mélange de graisses et de
foie d'oie ou canard non gavés
c'est donc plutôt un pâté il est
disponible dans cette chaîne de
supermarchés assez chic une enseigne qui
refuse de vendre du vrai foie gras au
nom de la défense des animaux causent
sacro-sainte en grande-bretagne arrêter
la torture du gavage disent ces
manifestants dans les rues de londres
un lobby efficace spécialiste des coups
d'éclat devant les restaurants et
magasins qui ont c'est encore vendre du
foie gras l'équivalent point d'être main
ce serait de lui faire avaler 12 kg de
farine d'eau tous les jours jusqu'à ce
que le voit éclater ces activistes
utilisent aussi pour convaincre ces
images doit gaver dans les pays de l'est
notre cher h est quant à lui son foie
gras en france où le garage
explique-t-il est moins agressif
confronté à cette pression constante des
activit les commerçants britanniques
cherchent des verbes dax de foie gras
mais celui ci n'est pas vraiment une
réussite
en bref un clin d'oeil amical à
véronique sainte olives du service
politique de france 2 des corps et en
fin d'après midi au conseil
constitutionnel chevalier de la légion
d'honneur par jacques chirac avant de
refermer ce journal un détour par le
plateau d'à vous de juger
bonsoir arlette chabot c'est dans
quelques instants et c'est ce soir le
grand retour de ségolène royal après six
mois de présidence de nicolas sarkozy
ségolène royal on sait pubit
vivre ma plus belle histoire c'est vous
il manque le mot amour mais on l'a
compris c'est un petit geste est un
signe qu'elle envoie à tous ceux et même
au delà qui ont voté ou n'ont pas voté
pour elle donc regard sur une campagne
regard aussi sur l'action du président
de la république quel sera son rôle
aussi au sein de la gauche demain à un
moment où beaucoup se demandent mais où
est le parti socialiste est d'ailleurs
je signale ce sera en deuxième partie
d'émission le thème du débat que nous
aurons entre autres avec olivier
besancenot julien dray et henri guaino
le conseiller spécial du président de la
république qui a mis jaurès et blum dans
ses discours
donc en attendant est tout de suite
c'est bien sûr le retour de ségolène
royal ce qu'elle a envie de dire
aujourd'hui aux français a tout de suite
tout cela à partir de 20h50 à tout de
suite arlette chabot une image du
mondial de hand ball les françaises ont
perdu ce soir face à l'angola lors du
premier match de la deuxième phase et se
sont inclinés à metz 29 à 27 prochain
match pour la france ce sera samedi face
à la macédoine
je vous rappelle l'un des principaux au
titre de cette édition de ce soir un
attentat au colis piégé a fait un mort
et cinq blessés à paris le paquet a été
livré un cabinet d'avocats et c'est une
secrétaire de ce cabinet qui a été tué
aucune piste n'est privilégiée ce soir
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko point route valérie
maurice et puis vous retrouvez donc à
vous de juger avec arlette chabot et
ségolène royal en première partie
d'émission très bonne soirée
l'info en continu c'est parti sur france
2 pourrait faire tourner